I never gave it enough consideration
that I would need something like this
this is opened my eyes to the world I
never take the time to really step back
and say what is going on in the business
world globally this is actually really
important we need to be smaller now
people women need to take the time and
focus just on you and we never do that
I was given the opportunity for my
company and I was hesitant at first
because I have a two-year-old at home
you've talked it over with your family
and your work and make sure that
everybody's on board I love every aspect
of my life but balancing things been a
big challenge one of my concerns was not
seeing my family so I Skyped with my
family every evening in the morning when
they wake up we FaceTime we FaceTime
every day so I see her on video talked
on the phone
my oldest who sign you Saul was able to
fly out and participate in a swim camp
from campus I got to see my mom a lot
words Stanford soccer camp it's really
really cool
sniper it's amazing oh yeah commended
it's a great experiment all these
friends I have a long career ahead of me
and I need something to give me more
energy and to build up my confidence to
take on a new challenge and I think that
this is a great program to do that we're
so busy all the time that I'm just
really happy that I've done it for
myself and also for my family my
experience Stanford was huge it comes
back to the confidence I've really been
confident that hey I am at the helm of
that leadership I can take this back and
not only do it for myself but for all
the other women I'm mentoring it's been
one of the best experiences of my life I
would HIGHLY encourage any woman to not
think twice about coming